معنا من جنين مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ابدا
معك ليث اذا بما يجري في حي الهدف هل من
تطورات نعم انسحب الاحتلال قبل لحظات فقط
من منطقه حي الهدف غرب المخيم بعد عمليه
عسكريه استمرت لقرابته نصف ساعه تم خلالها
اعتقال فلسطيني من هذه المنطقه حيث دفع
الاحتلال ايه وتسللت قوات خاصه اسرائيليه
الى منطقه حي الهدف ومن ثم تبعها تعزيزات
عسكريه اسرائيليه من حاجز دوتان غرب
المدينه وصلت هذه الاليات العسكريه الى
منطقه محيط المخيم وحي الهدف وسط
الاشتباكات المسلحه فور اكتشاف الوحدات
الخاصه الاسرائيليه التي حاولت التسلل الى
المخيم قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت الشاب صهيب
مجدي ابو الهيج النجل القيادي في حركه
حماس مجدي ابو الهيجه والاسير في سجون
الاحتلال منذ عده اشهر بعد اقتحام منزله
وا تخريب ممتلكات هذا المنزل وسط
الاشتباكات التي استمرت حتى انسحاب جيش
الاحتلال من محيط مخيم جنين بشكل كامل نحو
حاجز دوتان وايضا حاجز الجلمه الى الشمال
من المدينه خلال العمليه العسكريه دفع
الاحتلال وحاصر المنطقه الغربيه وواد برقي
ايه في هذه الاثناء واثناء هذه العمليه
العسكريه ايضا اقتحم الاحتلال منطقه او
بلده برقين المتاخمه لمخيم جنين وقامت
باعتقال الطفل الجريح فارس
شلاميط برصاص الاحتلال في منطقه الصدر
والبطن قبل اقل من شهر خلال اقتحام جيش
الاحتلال للمدينه قوات الاحتلال انسحبت
بشكل كامل من مدينه جنين ومخيمها وايضا
بلده برقين بعد تنفيذ هذه العمليه
العسكريه واعتقال شابين على الاقل حتى هذه
اللحظه من تم التعرف عليهم خلال هذه
العمليه العسكريه ايضا خلال ساعات الفجر
كان هناك اقتحام لبلده قباطيه الى الى
الشمال او عفوا الى الغرب من المدينه حيث
اقتحم عده احياء من البلده وسط اشتباكات
وانفجارات عده استمرت لقرابته
الساعه حيث نفذ الاحتلال حمله اعتقالات
واسعه داخل البلده شملت عدد من الاسرى
المحررين وعوائل ل مطلوبين كما يدعي
الاحتلال ومن ثم انسحب بشكل كامل نحو حاجز
دوتان هذه العمليه العسكريه تاتي في سياق
تواصل او مواصله الاحتلال في اعمالها
العسكريه والاقتحامات لمدن الضفه الغربيه
المحتله والتي تزايدت خلال الاشهر السابقه
هنا في مدينه جنين وشمال الضفه الغربيه
المحتله ايضا خلال ساعات الليل كان هناك
اقتحام لجيش الاحتلال لمدينه ومحافظه
طوباس من منطقه حاجز تياسير حيث تمركزت في
عده احياء من المدينه وايضا بلده تياسير
وايضا في مدينه قلقيليه كان هناك اقتحام
لج الاحتلال واعتقال لناشط سياسيه في
مدينه قلقيليه ومن ثم انسحب الاحتلال من
المدينه على الفور هذه العمليات العسكريه
متواصله في الضفه الغربيه المحتله هنا في
جنين التي باتت تشهد اقتحام شبه يومي
ل للمدينه
وقراها ضمن مسلسل الاحتلال المتواصل
للقضاء على المقاومين والعناصر والمظاهر
المسلحه في الضفه الغربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
ليف ج عار من
جنين